مدينه بورسودان المعروفه بهدوءها وسكونها
تضيق شوارعها باعداد النازحين والراغبين
بمغادره البلاد وضع فرض تداعيات انسانيه
عجلت بتحرك منظمات المجتمع المدني هنا
اجتمعت شرائحه مختلفه من المجتمع المحلي
تحت لافته الواحه الوريفه كواحده من
المبادرات لاطعام وايواء الفارين من ويلات
الحرب بدانا في عمليات الايواء وتجهيز
الطعام
والعلاج والحمد لله بلغنا عدد ثلاثه الف
وجبه في اليوم
موزعه على عده محاور على داخليه الشاحنات
فيها 850 فرد نيجيري وعلى داخليه البنات
جوار الاذاعه بها 520 امراه و146 طفل هنا
في مستقر للطلاب السودانيين والذي تحول
لمركزي ايواء للطلاب من نيجيريا تتجه
مبادره الواحه الوريفه يوميا اليه لتوفير
وجبه يتوارى بعضهم عند وصولها عن عدسات
الكاميرا فهم لم يتعودوا ان يعيشوا ظروفا
مثل هذه في السودان من قبل ولكنها الحرب
في اقصى تجلياتها
تقول السلطات بولايه البحر الاحمر انها
استقبلت حوالي 16 الف شخص من الرعايه
الاجانب ونحو سبعه الاف اسره سودانيه اثرا
اندلاع الحرب بين الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع تم توزيع معينات لعدد 10500 اسره
عبر معتمديه اللاجئين
البحر الاحمر من بدايه الاحداث يمكن تم
حصر في عده 5
يمكن التدخلات ل 1500 اسره دخلنا
توفير الموينات بطانيه فرشه ناموسيات من
حياه النظافه هكذا تفعل الحرب بالانسان
ففي ظل الاوضاع التي يعيشها السودان تبرز
المجهودات الخيريه للمنظمات التي تعمل في
مجال العون الانساني في محاوله لتقليل
تاثير الفجوه التي قد تتسع بازدياد وتيره
المعارك محمد عثمان العربيه من مدينه
البحر الاحمر شرقي السودان لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات